hey crazies I have received a challenge
so I've been thinking some crazy
thoughts and that is what would it take
to artificially generate a magnetic
field that would be strong enough to
protect the Martian atmosphere and that
requires some crazy physics so where
else do you go but the craziest people
in physics and that is in their science
asylum you know Phillip if we do this
right it might not be as crazy as it
sounds first let me explain the problem
with Mars it has a really thin
atmosphere and it's very cold it ranges
from about 400 Pascal's up to about 900
Pascal's that's pretty low compared to
Earth's atmosphere temperatures aren't
any better they range from about
negative 130 degrees Fahrenheit only up
to about negative 20 degrees Fahrenheit
it's basically a nice planet the
atmosphere is also 95% carbon dioxide
and there is no liquid water on its
surface as you can see from this fancy
phase diagram liquid water is physically
impossible under Mars as normal
conditions anyway none of this is great
for humans I mean your eyes aren't gonna
pop out of your face or anything but it
will definitely kill you and quickly it
wasn't always like this though as
Phillip mentioned when it comes to
terraforming mud one of the major
problems is the fact that Moz has a very
thin atmosphere because it has
essentially no magnetic field back in
the day it had a magnetic field which
means it had a thicker atmosphere which
means it had liquid water on its surface
it's just been about 4.2 billion years
ago the magnetic field turned off the
atmosphere stripped away and the water
either froze or evaporated and as Philip
pointed out if we go through all this
effort of generating in that misfeed we
don't want it to be blown away by the
solar winds which you know sounds
reasonable let's do this but Mars didn't
have the gravity over here oh it can't
you're right
you're right we'll deal with that first
there's another problem with Mars it
only has about 38% of Earth's surface
gravity the upside you can jump 2.6
times as high the downside it can only
hold on to about 38 percent as much
atmosphere as Earth we can't fix the
surface gravity problem
so the highest the pressure could ever
get is 0.38 atmospheres that's roughly
the pressure near the peak of Mount
Everest it's not enough to walk around
outside without an oxygen mask but it's
definitely enough for some liquid water
now let's do this
okay let's see Elon Musk wants to use
nukes
we'd have to drill down to the Martian
core and detonate the nukes there that
would really ko Phi the core and get it
moving again but it seems like it would
take a lot of energy
considering the course current
temperature and pressure would give us a
density specific heat and latent heat
allowing us to calculate mass and
ultimately thermal energy which comes to
approximately ten to the twenty-nine
joules that's ten trillion megatons or
hundreds of billions of the largest nuke
ever created I don't think this is gonna
work even if we could do this somehow
there's no guarantee that the liquid
core would actually generate a magnetic
field and even then we'd have to keep
the core from cooling off again we need
a better option hmm I've got it who says
in this magnetic field has to be created
by the planet or even on it let's just
put a big magnet in space unfortunately
we can't just put this thing into orbit
around Mars because we need it to always
be between Mars and the Sun we need a
lagron joint there are five points in
and around a circular orbit that are
stable other objects can sit in them and
they'll all orbit together any deviation
and the object gets tugged back into
place they're very useful for human-made
probes for our space magnet l1 will do
quite nicely l1 for Mars is about a
hundred and sixty Mars's away from ours
that looks something like this it's
really far away so we'd need it to be
strong enough that Mars would still be
inside of it which isn't actually that
difficult Earth's magnetic field is only
about thirty to sixty microteslas and
the moon is inside it remember how far
away the moon is this I don't even need
to calculate because NASA scientists
already did it dr. Jim Green and a team
of planetary scientists ran computer
simulations for a space magnet at l1
according to them and magnet anywhere
from 50 to 500 micro Tesla's should do
the trick we can
easily generate that with current
technology if we did this Mars's
atmosphere would thicken over time on
its own because it's not being blasted
away by the solar wind the northern
polar icecap is a bunch of frozen water
covered in a thin layer of dry ice as
the atmosphere thickens the temperature
will rise and that ice cap will melt
first the dry ice releasing more co2 a
known greenhouse gas this will speed up
the warming process even more which will
help melt the frozen water underneath
eventually liquid water will be able to
flow in the surface as much as 1/7 of
Mars's ancient ocean could come back
making Mars look like it did in the good
old days
again there won't be enough pressure to
you know breathe but it'll make
colonizing Mars a heck of a lot easier
so I've got one thing to say to you NASA
get your boss got any questions about
Mars please ask in the comments thanks
for liking and sharing this video don't
forget to subscribe if you'd like to
keep up with us and until next time
remember it's okay to be a little crazy
the featured comment comes from Bill
DeWitt who suggested an alternate name
for spin aim angular intrinsic momentum
it's aimed up or down you know that's
not that bad I think I'll propose it at
the next science and sanity meeting
anyway thanks for watching
[Music]